for
her name is in. She is student. Her
parents are Christians. She has a maf
other than dua. What dwah methodologies
can she endeavor to uh to get her
parents to come closer to Islam. If you
want your parents to come closer to
Islam, dua is very important. Beside
that you should do dava. You can give my
video classes to them. Give my booklets.
This talk itself is a very good talk.
Similarities between Islam and
Christianity. If they cannot come here,
you give a recording to them. You can
ask them to watch it. There are my other
talks Bible and Quran in the light of
science. Another talk Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam in the Bible.
Another talk concept of God in major
world. All these talks give them ask
them to watch and we pray that may Allah
give them ha. You see to it that you
love them, you respect them. Don't don't
be disfaithful to them. They are your
parents. The more you are respectful for
them and then do dawa, there are more
chances they will listen.